I went to see the first Star Wars movie
in June of 1977 the thing that I still
remember best is the opening sequence
where the Imperial Class Star Destroyers
moving across the screen and my first
thought was what society had the
capability to build a machine of such
grand size
if one wanted to build a Death Star you
didn't build it by launching a bunch of
stuff off a planet you went and got
yourself an asteroid and built it from
that could provide the metals of organic
compounds you have water all the
building blocks you would need to build
your family Death Star on my asteroid
redirect mission we're going to go land
on an asteroid it's just stories tonight
there's no way to go it looks pretty
good
we're going to go hiccup a boulder from
the surface put it in orbit around the
moon we will go and visit it with a
crewed mission and bring back samples we
would land there about 2023 you crazy to
follow us with the ability to sense that
something's ahead of you and react so
quickly that's that's a hard problem
ever tell me the odds playing quickly
through an asteroid fields a problem
find more slowly through an asteroid
field yes you absolutely can do that we
have dawn it's flying through the main
belt asteroids there's a lot of space
between them and we can fly through them
key technology behind all that is ion
propulsion which of course is the
propulsion or sub light spacecraft in
the Star Wars series we actually have
four ion engines on the asteroid
redirect mission that's an ion engine
obviously those engines have to be very
maneuverable something that massive to
turn like that takes a lot of force so
you need really powerful engines to do
that ion engines today they're very low
thrust if you wanted to start going to
the stars
you need much more advanced power so
that's where you start talking about
fission and then fusion that's really
one of the power systems that the star
wars use